hello everyone and welcome to a truly
remarkable game from round 7 of the US
Championship 2022 now it's a game that
has advertised the last only 10 moves
and it's very hard to imagine such a
game in a game between two grand Masters
so it's a game between uh linear
Dominguez Perez uh and uh Elsa and
moradabadi who formerly playing for Iran
now represents the United States and you
can see there's quite a difference in
the ELO uh here linear is 2747 and alsan
uh or elshon I don't know how the name
is pronounced is 2534 but even this
difference in raiding uh it's very hard
to imagine something like this happening
but it is well a good a good tell that
you should definitely study the openings
and it's very hard to mix them up so uh
the the two of them have met previously
I think they they have met in the video
World Cup 2021 where a linear eliminated
elsan from from the first round but this
is is now 11 years have passed after the
game so a nice opportunity for alsanta
exact his revenge so let's see what
happened in this game and they play a
very very popular opening the Petra of
Defense so here on the E4 by Lanier and
E5 while Sun Knight to F3 Knight to F6
the Petra of defense is on the board and
Knight captures on E5 so this is the
classical variation nothing new here D6
Knight F3 and Knight captures on e4 so
we've seen this many times as this is
one of the most popular oldest openings
D4 D5 and now Bishop to D3
uh known as the classical attack against
the Petrov and now again this position
has been reached countless times even
last year in the World Chess
Championship Match in round four uh
Magnus Carlson played this against diani
pomnishi uh the game ended in a draw but
in the game Bishop to D6 was played also
a nice continuation is Knight to C6 but
in this game we have Bishop to this
bishop D7 and this is also one of the
three most popular continuations along
with Bishop D6 and Knight to C6 so
nothing odd Happening Here we have
castles and now comes a move that's a
bit rare here uh you either go Knight C6
or castles but here we have Bishop to F5
now I don't know if this is a mixing up
the opening or maybe this was some sort
of a nasty preparation to catch a linear
off guard however it did not go very
well and linear goes Pawn to C4 and what
you should do here is just capture the
pawn just capture the pawn and don't
even think about it but in the game
elsan just castled which is a standard
movie these are all moves you want to
play when you're playing the Petrov
maybe just not in this order and now
just see captures on D5 and that's a
free pawn and there's no good way to win
the pawn back so best thing for black
would be to
just pretend that this was a pawn
sacrifice maybe you go some Knight to D6
and then you you trade Bishops maybe or
or do something and okay white is up a
pawn but it's a double the D Pawn it's
uh maybe will not lose the game over
this however in the game Elsa captured
on D5 and this loses the game on the
spot this is only move nine but white is
now completely winning but you have to
figure out what else I missed so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
win this game for Lanier while I give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
bishop on E7 is undefended and basically
hanging whatever whatever black plays
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Bishop captures on
e4 uh this is what linear played and uh
elsan spent some time here trying to
figure out if there is any way out of
this but he decided that there is no
going back and he was in this position
unmoved and that Elsa and moradia body
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here a problem is the
bishop on E7 is lost whatever you do if
you capture with the queen uh just Rook
the E1 and the queen has no squares the
bishop is hanging the the H4 Square
covered by the Knight and there are no
more squares that the queen can Retreat
to as you can see here none of those
squares are sufficient to defend the
bishop and even capturing with the light
Square Bishop doesn't help because if
you capture now there's this very nasty
Knight the C3 most likely what the elsan
missed in all of this because now you
will again Force The Black Queen to E4
doesn't matter where the black queen
moves to you're just gonna capture an E4
and play rookie one and the bishop on E7
is lost and also after
this Knight the C3 it doesn't even help
if you play Bishop captures on F3 you
attack the White Queen because now just
Knight captures on D5 and you have to
take back the queen otherwise you're
down a queen so Bishop captures and
again the bishop on E7 hangs but he
hangs with checks so Knight captures on
E7 comes with Tempo the black king now
has the move and now you just collect
the bishop on D1 and if you counted the
pieces uh White is up a full Bishop so
of course there's no point in playing
this after Bishop captures on e4 Elson
resigned and a well-deserved victory for
Lanier Dominguez Perez and uh well even
even 11 11 years after that game in the
video World Cup elsehan was unable to
exact his revenge so it's a it's a sad
sad way to end the game but uh for for
us who are merely enjoying address it is
a very important not to mess up the
openings even if you know where which
piece goes you do not want to mess up
the move order as that can also be very
very important even as as we've shown
here even if you are a grand master of a
2534 rating so okay if it happens to
them it will happen to us nothing out of
the ordinary here but I thought you
might I thought you guys might enjoy
this one as well it's a very very
popular opening and the move order
really matters uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed a bit of a
shorter video but we've had a couple of
very long videos
um so I thought it'd be nice to throw in
a short one hope you guys enjoyed this I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to Shannon who allows her husband to
watch chess videos whenever he wants
that's I mean what more could you ask
for and I would like to thank Bjorn
Bartel Alan wienery congratulations Dr
taco and Francis air for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day